appears video of the director of the FBI
right now his name's Christopher Ray
he's over there not sure what he's doing
there I thought he was supposed to be
over here in America I'm sure we have
something he could be doing right some
pushing papers across the desk or
something but here he is talking about
how private and public collaboration has
made great strides to
basically watch us and I think the
sophistication of the private sector is
is improving and and particularly
important the level of collaboration
between the private sector and the
government especially the FBI has I
think made significant strides pretty
much every technology we could talk
about today
we see both great opportunity but great
great dangers uh in the wrong hand I
have to say that I wish that the
director of the FBI wasn't evil that's
not a fun thing you know the director of
the FBI but there he is basically saying
that everything that we've talked about
here for months related to Elon Musk who
is completely against the Wes by the way
and making fun of it every day on
Twitter that everything that he has
released with the Twitter files is true
that there is a public private
partnership
the FBI is involved and they are
interested in stifling misinformation
which is really also known as truth and
that they're working together and it
seems to be getting stronger and he's
very happy about it that seems as the
kids say problematic
[Music]